canyons in nairobi's industrial area are
rushing to beat the evening rush hour a
majority of them are casual laborers
looking for jobs some left early in the
morning
many will walk home having earned no
money
the conversation here is about the
upcoming general election some young
people say they are still undecided
i'm not working
we are hustling
they say they want to help us
they say this all the time
we want change
nothing has changed yet we need change
more than 22 million kenyans have
registered to vote most of them are
young but they are also frustrated they
say they have no jobs the cost of living
is unbearable and they don't trust
politicians
those vying for electoral positions have
been trying to woo young people with
lofty promises
runs a non-profit organization that
helps young people to get involved in
politics some are making an effort
others say they're not bothered the
major two coalitions they have very
similar because they focus on the
economy a lot so they both focus on the
economy they both focus on agriculture
they both focus on social welfare they
might use different methods or avenues
but a lot of them mean we need a lot of
money so a lot of youth are concerned
about where you're going to get those
resources
the polls suggest two presidential
frontrunners opposition leader rylo
odinga and the deputy president william
ruto who have made promises to the youth
in the past so our politics is not
delivering
to people
it's not putting money in their pockets
it's not giving them a sense of
security about their future
um
they and they don't believe the
politicians they feel that there's a
game being played
by these big guys in their helicopters
and problems up there
and that's not always a healthy
thing
people we have talked to say they want
leaders who will make their life easier
but they also express doubt it will
happen catherine soy al jazeera nairobi